[موسيقى]
إنها البداية غير الرسمية للصيف ولكن
هذا اليوم التذكاري لا يشبه
أي زملاء آخرين مع
الأمراض المعدية التي
تحدث عنها المجتمع الأمريكي عن الأنشطة الصيفية يقول الدكتور بريتي
ميلاني إن
الفطرة السليمة ستكون أساسية
لمنع انتشار فيروس كورونا بشكل أكبر
نريد أن نزرع الزهور في
حديقتنا إذا كنت تقود سيارتك إلى الحضانة
ورأيت أن هناك مئات
السيارات
في ساحة انتظار السيارات ، فقد لا يكون هذا
وقتًا آمنًا للتسوق ،
وربما تحتاج إلى العودة لاحقًا في هذه
العطلة ، فقد تجد نفسك
في حمام السباحة ، قال الدكتور ليونارد ميرمل إن
حمامات الكلور وأحواض المياه البلدية
يجب أن تكون على مستوى
يكافح فيروس كورونا ،
ولست قلقًا من أنه سيكون هناك
انتقال في الماء والمسبح
أكثر مع الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم قريبين من
بعضهم البعض في هذا المكان
إذا  كنت تخطط للسفر إيجارات منزل
ويجب تطهير الفنادق وفقًا لإرشادات cdc ،
يجب أن تحصل على تأكيدات بأن
التنظيف المناسب
يتم لكاملها  إن الحصول على أسطح
عالية اللمسة مرة أخرى
هذا الصيف سيحدد أيضًا
نغمة سقوط ميلاني يقترح نهجًا تدريجيًا
للعودة إلى الرياضات مثل
كرة القدم ، من الصعب حقًا ترك مسافة جسدية
في ممارسة الرياضة ، لذلك هناك هذا
الجانب وهناك أيضًا جوانب المتفرج
وهذا هو  سيكون أحد
الأسئلة العديدة التي يتم النظر إليها هذا
الصيف في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا
ماندي غايثر